everything you've talked about from
starting from the basic elements with
the big bang the somehow created the Sun
that somehow uh said Fu to uh
thermodynamics and created life and all
the ways that you've talked about from
ribosomes that created the Machinery
that created the machine and then now
the biological machine creating
through digital fabrication more complex
artificial machines all of that this is
a magic to that creative process and we
notice we humans are smart enough to
notice the magic so it's you haven't
said the s word yet
um which one is that singularity
[Laughter]
yeah I'm not sure if Ray Kurzweil is
listening if he is high Ray but I have a
complex relationship with Rey because a
lot of the things he projects I find
annoying
but then he does his homework and then
somewhat annoyingly he points out how
almost everything I'm doing fits on his
road maps yeah
um and so
you know the
the the
question is are we heading towards the
singularity I
so I'd have to say I lean towards
sigmoids rather than exponentials
um we've done pretty well with the
sigmoids yeah so sigmoids are things
grow and they taper and then there can
be one after it and one after it so
um
you know I'll pass on whether there's
enough of them that that they diverge
but you know to
the selfish Gene answer to the meaning
of life is the meaning of life is the
propagation of life and so
um
you know it it was a step for atoms to
assemble into a molecule
um for molecules to assemble into a
protocell
for the protocell to form to then form
organelles for the organ cells to form
organs the organs to form an organism
then it was a step for organisms to form
family units then family units to form
Villages you can view you know each of
those as a stack in the level of
organizations so you could view
everything we've spoken about as
the imperative of life
just the next step in the hierarchy of
that and the Fulfillment of the
inexorable Drive of the violation of
thermodynamics so you know you could
view you know I'm an embodiment of the
will of the violation of thermodynamics
speaking
the two of us having having an old chat
yes yeah
um and so continues and even then the
singularity is just to transition up the
ladder there's nothing deeper to
Consciousness than it it it's a derived
property of distributed problem solving
um there's nothing deeper to life than
embodied AI
in morphogenesis